il est 7 heures du matin ce jeudi un
embouteillage s'est formé à l'entrée de
la centrale nucléaire de golfech
l'accès au site est ralentie par un
barrage filtrant à l'appel de la cgt et
des salariés sont en grève et souhaite
sensibiliser leurs collègues à leur
mouvement
le projet de restructuration de
l'entreprise nommé recul représente à
leurs yeux une menace donc les
conséquences du recul ça va être la mise
en concurrence de toutes les entreprises
par des fêtes de la scission du groupe
en plusieurs morceaux avec une des
parties privées des parties
des partis est plutôt à l'état les
partis qui rapporte de l'argent seront
seront là pour donner des dividendes aux
actionnaires alors que les partis qui
méritent de l'investissement comme le
nucléaire par exemple sera plutôt côté
côté public donc en fait on privatise
les bénéfices et on socialise les pertes
dans ce projet voulu par la commission
européenne qui souhaite mettre fin au
monopole d'edf
le gouvernement a tenté de rassurer un
peu par la voix de bruno le maire mardi
lors de ses voeux à la presse
aujourd'hui edf va dans le mur si nous
ne sommes pas capables de lui donner les
moyens d'investir
ma responsabilité de ministre de
l'économie et des finances c'est de
donner à edf les moyens de se développer
et de rester l'une des plus grandes
entreprises énergéticienne de la planète
c'est ça l'objectif des mots de bruno le
maire qui n'ont pas forcément convaincu
les salariés craignent pour leurs
conditions de travail dans le nucléaire
il sera sous couvert de l'état et cela
risque d'engendrer qu'en termes de
difficulté un travail similaire à celui
des hôpitaux et issement moindre 1 et
des conditions de travail qui risque de
se dégrader
une dégradation des conditions de
travail qui inquiète une partie du
personnel y compris au sujet du maintien
du niveau de sûreté
face à ce projet hercules qui devraient
également avoir pour répercussion
d'augmenter encore les factures et les
impôts des usagers les syndicats
semblent déterminés à ne rien lâcher
ce jeudi ils étaient en grève pour la
quatrième fois en un mois